comics
let me introduce our speaker for today's
session so dr taylor joined lsu hsc new
orleans in december 2012 as an associate
professor in the department of
microbiology immunology and parasitology
he is a founding member of the microbial
genomics resource group and has built an
informatics laboratory at the school of
medicine focused on microbial community
sequencing analysis and visualization
he was appointed in july 2016 as the
director of the bioinformatics
biostatistics and computational biology
core of the louisiana biomedical
research network lvrn and was awarded
tenure from lsu hsc new orleans in 2017
dr taylor co-organizes an annual
conference on bioinformatics and
computational biology for lbrn and his
research laboratory maintains several
terabytes of sequence data and designs
innovative software systems for
visualization and analysis of high
throughput sequencing experiments he
also serves as the contact pi for a
recently awarded nsf grant that was
utilized to acquire and establish a high
performance computing cluster called
tiger fish for computational biology and
bioinformatics research at lsu hsc new
orleans dr taylor's research interests
currently focuses on dynamic changes in
the vaginal microbiota associated with
various stis including pv chlamydia and
hiv
so without wasting any further time i
would like to transfer this virtual
podium to today's guest speaker dr
christopher m taylor dr taylor the stage
is all yours and welcome to psionics how
you are doing
thank you um
i'm gonna see if i can get my screen
share
going
yep we can see your screen well
is it in
presentation mode
yeah all right i'm good to go
so um thanks for uh
the uh invitation to speak and uh the
introduction um
as
as was said my name is christopher
taylor and i'm an associate professor at
the louisiana state
health sciences center in new orleans in
the school of medicine
and
my background is actually in computer
science
and i got involved in working with
genomics in the early 2000s soon after
the human genome was sequenced and
so i come at this
this field from a computational
perspective
so i like to kind of think about
computational biology as bridging the
gap between
the fields of computing and biology and
and bioinformatics in particular
requires
the application of computing technology
and programming to solve biological
problems and
in my lab in particular we often have
people who come from either side
from either of these fields
and
they bring unique perspectives depending
upon what their background is
so my major focus of the work that i do
is the human microbiome
we also study a lot of environmental
samples and we look at
animal models but most of my work
in my research
tries to attack problems that are
associated with human health and disease
because we are in the school of medicine
at louisiana state university
and as as was said the human body is
covered in bacteria you have bacteria
that lives on the surface of your skin
in your nose and your mouth your ear
your lungs your stomach your intestines
and reproductive tract
and those communities of bacteria can be
significant factors in health and
disease and indeed some diseases
are actually defined as as as a change
in those microbial communities
and the nih has funded uh since i think
2012 a uh care
an initiative to characterize the
bacteria that live in and upon the body
called the human microbiome project and
that has had
several iterations since it was
initiated
so in terms of how we refer to uh the
terminology
when we say microbiota that refers to an
ecological community of organisms some
of them are commensal
and some of them are symbiotic and
others pathogenic
this definition came out of the human
microbiome project working group
and technically microbiota includes not
only bacteria but also other
microbiological organisms such as
archaea protists fungi and viruses
however
often when people use the term
microbiota they implicitly mean just the
bacteria because that is
one of the more often studied
areas
and then if we say microbiome then
definitionally that technically refers
to the collective genomes of all the
microorganisms
that make up a given environmental niche
as opposed to microbiota which is
supposed to just refer to the organisms
themselves but often these terms are
used fairly interchangeably and i use
them interchangeably myself
even though that definitionally they
have different connotations
then there's also this a more
interesting idea of a holobiont which
refers to the host organism plus all of
the symbiotic microbes
that live in and upon it
and
that sort of way of looking at things
leads to a
recasting of the traditional theory of
evolution called the holo genome theory
of evolution
which
views not only the host organisms
as evolving over time but also the
community of microbes
that live in and upon those host
organisms
have also evolved together over time
then there's this term dysbiosis which
you've probably heard and it's really
used as a catch-all term
for some form of microbial imbalance
that occurs in one of the sites on the
body
normally the healthy community that is
normal at a given location it becomes
somehow deranged
and the species that normally make up
that community
decrease in abundance and allow for
opportunistic species to grow
most commonly dysbiosis is discussed in
terms of the gastrointestinal tract
which is gut dysbiosis
but that concept can actually affect any
of the common sites of microbial
colonization in particular i look a lot
at vaginal dysbiosis
the
change in this community of organisms or
this dysbiosis it can lead to or it can
be the result of a disease
and possible therapies for dysbiotic
states
are antibiotics which will kill for a
variety of bacteria
probiotics whereby you're trying to add
back
so-called good bacteria
or even a more extreme treatment fmt
which stands for fecal microbiota
transfer
and that's actually a technique that's
been used fairly successfully
to treat uh recurrent antibiotic
resistant clostridium difficile
infection
so in terms of genomics technology dna
sequencing is the major tool that we use
and it's the process of determining the
identity and the order
of the nucleotides in a given piece of
genetic material whether that's dna or
it's cdna from an rna
molecule
and
the term genomics is the study of the
complete genome of a selected organism
and that includes all the dna sequences
and all of the genes of that organism in
question
so then when you get um
to the term metagenomics it actually
adds in not only the host organism but
as was said studying the genetic
material from all the organisms
and with all the recent advances that
have occurred in dna sequencing
technologies they brought about a
revolution in genomics over the past
decade
and so the best way
of visualizing this is a graph that the
nhgri the national human genome research
institute maintains
and this graph
shows from the year 2000
the cost
of
sequencing basically so this is cost per
megabase of sequence
and so um if you look at this
way back in 2000 the sequencing was
done via a technique called sanger
sequencing that was really the
the primary method for doing dna
sequencing
and that technology had been around
since the late 70s and early 80s so it
had dominated the field of dna
sequencing for over 20 years and you can
see that it was uh fairly expensive to
sequence megabase of dna
you know this is ten thousand dollars up
here
at the very top
of the screen
and that's what it cost back in 2000
see if i can hide some of these bars
floating meeting controls okay
and so as time went on uh from 2000 to
about 2007
the reduction in cost of dna sequencing
was roughly following what's called
moore's law which is a an observation
not so much a law but an observation
in computing
that in the 80s and 90s and 2000s the
cost of computing was decreasing and
roughly being cut in half
about every 18 months well
cost of dna sequencing was also being
cut in half about every 18 months and
was following this white line
but suddenly
in about 2007 2008 this reduction in
cost of sequencing
really accelerated
and far outpaced even moore's law
which is is very um impressive because
we know how how much
computing power and the cost of
computing has dropped
over the course of the last 40 or 50
years well cost of sequencing was even
dropping at a much more rapid pace
until about nowadays in the last two
three years
you can sequence a megabase of dna which
is a million base pairs
for about a cent
this is all on a log scale by the way
so this reduction in the cost of
sequencing has obviously opened up the
possibility of people being able to
afford to use sequencing to tackle many
problems that couldn't have been tackled
even say 10 years ago
so metagenomics is um essentially
extending the concept of genomics which
focuses on a single organism to
look at all of the organisms that live
in a community
organisms that live in communities and
interact if you want to study those
communities you need to look across all
the genomes of the organisms living in
it
and that is by definition what
metagenomics does
it's the study of metagenomes or genetic
material that is sampled directly from a
given environment
and this allows us to study communities
of organisms directly in their natural
environment you just sample the dna that
you find regardless of what organism it
comes from
and you sequence it and this bypasses
the need
for isolating particular organisms that
you want to study and cultivating them
in the lab because
we found that a lot of the organisms
that we find in the environment in the
natural environment are fairly resistant
to cultivation in the lab
so the primary tool that we have used
and have used in the past to study
these metagenomes is what's called 16s
ribosomal rna
this is a gene
and the schematic on this slide is the
16s ribosomal rna gene
from an organism called
thermosthermophilus and essentially
um
the important thing about this gene
is that it's a high it's got some highly
conserved areas this gene is essential
for life and so there are various parts
of this gene
where the dna sequence is nearly
identical across
all bacteria
and that allows for so-called universal
pcr primers to be designed to those
highly conserved regions such that you
can take dna
taken from an environment which may have
come from all kinds of different
bacteria
and you can amplify
just this one gene from those bacterial
species
this gene is also important because in
between these highly conserved regions
are what are called hypervariable
regions and these are regions that are
less conserved and they have more
species specific
variation and so the signatures or the
dna sequence that's found in between
these highly conserved areas that falls
in these hypervariable regions
allows for you to then go back and match
against the database
and figure out
which bacterium
each of your 16s ribosomal rna
molecules that you've sequenced have
come from
so this method
i like to call it a bacterial census
because all it does is it goes in
takes material from a community
amplifies it and just tries to answer
the question which bacteria are there
and
who are they what type of bacteria and
in what abundance
and so if you if you look at the 16s
ribosomal rna and you stretch it out
it's about 1500 base pairs or more long
and if you look at the variability of it
in 50 base pair windows
this is what you get so the y-axis is
higher is increasing variability
and so you have all these areas that are
low variability
but they're interspersed with these high
variability areas and the high
variability or hyper variable regions
have been named v1 v2 v3 v4 v5 all the
way up through v9
and they correspond to these peaks and
so what we'll do in order to perform
such a bacterial census we will design a
primer let's say in this area which is
highly conserved
and another primer in this area
and then we will pcr amplify
the entire amplicon in between which
includes the v3 hypervariable region and
then we'll sequence it and use the
sequence of the v3 hypervariable region
to match back to a 16s database to
figure out
which bacteria were there and in what
quantities
now
there's another more powerful technique
but also more expensive which is called
shotgun metagenomics and this is often
what people mean when they say
metagenomics even though technically
metagenomics refers to the concept of
studying these microbial communities
but what shotgun metagenomics is is it's
you take the same type of sample you
just take all the dna you find in an
environment
but instead of
amplifying up just this one gene from
all the bacterial organisms
you actually sequence all the dna
and when you sequence all the dna you're
going to get dna from the host organism
if you were sampling from say the
surface of the skin or
if you're sampling in an environmental
area like in the soil you may get dna
from animals that live there
but also you're going to get dna from
the bacteria that's there
fungi
viruses everything and then you just
shotgun it up which means
basically mechanically fragmented to
small pieces that can be sequenced and
then you take a look
at what was there
and this has the advantage that it's
it's fair it's unbiased compared to 16s
because 16s you have the pcr step which
can bias what you find
where shotgun metagenomics you're just
sequencing everything and you're not pcr
amplifying it beforehand
now
that has its pluses and minuses one of
the minuses of that is that if you are
taking a sample from a host let's say
you're taking a
a sample from the surface of the skin
you're going to get a lot of dna that is
host
and you're also going to get some
bacteria you're going to get some fungi
viruses and so on well if you're
primarily interested in
the the microbial organisms
much of your sequencing effort is
actually going to go towards the host
it can be up depending on what type of
sample you have it can be up to 90 plus
percent
of your sequencing might be human let's
say if you're taking a microbial sample
from a human
but
so you may have to do a lot more
sequencing in order to answer the
question that you want to answer but if
you think back to that cost of
sequencing dropping as much as has
that allows you to do
a lot more sequencing for
less cost
so but one of the things that i want to
highlight is is and we're we're looking
at this in terms of a project where
we've done both 16s ribosomal rna
sequencing
and we've also done shotgun metagenomics
on the same samples
and one thing that you
get is when you
match the 16s ribosomal rna back to
databases
often you can only unambiguously
determine
the genus of the organisms that are
present
you don't get down to the species level
very often often you get stuck at the
genus level and that's just because the
16s sequence
may be equally close to
many different species of the same genus
but with shotgun metagenomics if you're
primarily interested in the taxonomic
composition the majority of your reeds
you can get to species level or even
potentially beyond to strain level
so that is a major advantage of using
shotgun metagenomics
and so i'll just show you an example
this is
one of the subjects that we
did 16s ribosomal rna sequencing on
and this is a this is a study of
women and it's it's looking at their
vaginal microbiome
and some of the women
come down with a dysbiotic condition
which is called bacterial vaginosis and
this is a condition where
as i said before the normally dominating
species of organisms in the environment
start to become less prevalent
and other opportunistic organisms come
in and start to take over
and so what this this heat map is
showing is actually it's a time course
and these are days of the study so this
time course where we started sequencing
was day 36 for this particular subject
and we went all the way through day 66
and on the x-axis are the different
organisms that we found
and uh we tried to classify as far down
as we could we could get to species
level in many cases
um but also lots of times we're only
left at like say the genus level
but what you can see from this
particular subject
is that
originally
her vaginal microbiome is dominated by a
couple of species of lactobacillus so
this one lactobacillus crespatus
and this other one lactobacillus
gaseride
are primarily the dominant organisms
there's a number of other things here
but up through about day 49 this is what
dominates
then we have some metadata up here and
you can see that on day 50
this subject
reports that mensie starts
well when mensie starts
she starts to lose the dominance of
almost immediately really she loses the
dominance of lactobacillus chrospatus
and jenseni
and a number of other organisms start to
come in and proliferate
and then
continuing along
she reports sexual activity
on day 56 after which suddenly
her lactobacillus is completely gone
and now the dominant organisms are
gardnerella vaginalis which is a
bacteria that's been implicated in
bacterial vaginosis
along with
prevotellabivia
and adipobeam vaginae and a few other
organisms anaerococcus tetradius
and so she ends up at this point
in a state of having bv and this is
something that we measure with what's
called a nugent score and as long as the
nugent score is three or below
we say she has a normal microbiota
but once it rises to four to six we'll
say
that the woman has an intermediate
microbiome and if she gets to a seven or
above she's diagnosed with bv and so you
can see that she jumps
from this normal
microbiota to suddenly a bv microbiota
which persists for several days
but then once mensie ceases
she
goes back to a lactobacillus dominant
microbiota so essentially her
normally dominating cresponus and
jensenite come back
and once again dominate her community
so the interesting thing here is that
for this same subject
we chose
a subset of samples
leading up
to
her diagnosis of bv
and we did shotgun sequencing on them so
due to cost considerations we didn't do
every day we did every other day so we
did day 47 49 51 53 55
and then day 57 which was the day she
was diagnosed with bv
and when we look at that
using shotgun
methods
we find very similar results
now one of the drawbacks that you can
have with shotgun uh sequencing for
metagenomics is that the matching to the
databases might not be as is it can be
more precise but there are a lot more
blind spots because not all of the
bacteria
have had their whole genome sequenced
whereas the 16s ribosomal rna sequences
have been studied
very thoroughly
and often will be available for you to
match against
but what you see
is very similar to what we saw with the
16s is that
you know initially she's dominated by
this lactobacillus correspondus and
lactobacillus gastrin
and then
you also see here that she has another
species of lactobacillus which didn't
pop up in the 16s lactobacillus
vaginalis and that's just because it
it's close enough to the other organisms
that it's not
able to be discerned from those other
organisms by 16s but you can by shotgun
and then what you see is that the
gardnerella vaginalis starts to dominate
here
and also privatel obivia
and
a few other organisms but
notice here
that the granularity of detail is finer
you can actually see that
the gardener ella vaginalis was there at
low levels
even when she was dominated by
lactobacilli
when you look back at these graphs
you can also see that it was there at
fairly low levels leading up
but you can see a progressive ramp up
here of adipobian vagina which really
dominates
on the day of bv but you can see it it
ramps up here you can also see a ramping
up but at a quicker rate of private
labia
so these are sort of
just an example to show you the types of
things that you can see with shotgun
sequencing compared to what you can see
with 16s and we actually did this on
three other subjects
which i don't have time to show you the
data for
but
this method allows us to not only look
at
the bacterial communities but we also
were able to find
that there's a little bit of fungal um
candida albicans that shows up in one of
our subjects and then there's also some
viral sequences so um alpha papilloma
virus is present in subject k-12
and human herpes virus 4 is
present in subject k-20 and these are
things that you don't find with 16s
ribosomal rna sequencing
so with the shotgun sequencing we could
actually go in and um look at you know
not only
sorry
eh
okay i think somebody's off of mute that
doesn't mean to be off of mute
so
when we look at all the data that we got
from our shotgun metagenomics as i said
the majority of the sequence was human
actually
84.62 percent of our sequencing data
mapped to human
whereas only 12.4 percent
mapped to bacteria and 2.92 percent
mapped to other microbial organisms
and then if you zoom in on the other
microbial organisms
71 percent of that sequence was fungal
27 protozoan a little over a percent are
kill and then very little of it about
less than one percent was viral
if we zoom in on that viral sequence
you can see a variety of different
viruses we found we found alpha
papilloma virus
uh human gamma herpes virus those are
the things that showed up on those heat
maps i showed you we found some other
viral sequences as well
and then one of the things that we're
really interested in is bacteriophage so
subset of the viral sequences was
bacteriophage
and we found a few lactobacillus phages
that's the majority of what we found and
we found a number of other phages so
this just gives you an idea of all the
different things that you can see
when you when you pay
for the additional uh cost of doing
shotgun metagenomic sequencing
and i'd imagine
you know that the
the thing that's popping into your head
right now or at least should be is uh
what is the cost differential well
basically for us um
i'm one of the founding members of our
micro of our metagenomics resources at
lsu health sciences we have a group
that's called
the microbial genomics resource group
and we we perform these kinds of assays
for people around the world
primarily we work with people
in our general area but we've done
sequencing of samples for places as far
as puerto rico and even some places in
europe
and
our cost it cost us about 40 to 45
dollars to process
a single sample
for 16s so that includes
dna isolation
uh amplicon preparation
and
indexing and sequencing so that's all
the molecular aspects of it
whereas if we're doing shotgun
sequencing
it's going to cost us
at least 200 per sample and that is
entirely dependent upon how much depth
of sequencing
is needed so if you need more depth you
want really deep shotgun metagenomics
we may
it may cost us 300 maybe 400.
shallow shotgun
could be 200
and it's partly dependent upon what
sequencing platforms we have available
but i i have a
a web server
which i i host
and if you you know roll run over to
that web page
if you continue to have issues please
contact support
that's alexa
all right so if you run over to
metagenomics this website
what you're going to find is
various links so i have some recorded
lectures on informatics
i have a link to my lab page and then i
have a link to the microbial genomics
resource group
and the microbial genomics resource
group if you you know visit that webpage
we have
a bunch of information there about what
we do who we are
former members of the group
a variety of news items and then
importantly probably the most useful
you know after you get through all the
publications is this cost and sample
submission which
lists out all of the different services
that we have available and the prices
for each and then we have some sample
submission guidelines
but i just wanted to you know highlight
that um
that that resource is available and we
work with people all around the world
as i also mentioned there on that same
website the lectures button
takes you to a series of lectures that i
conducted several years ago that have
been recorded
and are available via streaming
these recorded lectures persist and are
available for viewing on demand i did a
lecture series in general on an
introduction to informatics and then
another one that was an introduction to
microbial communities
i also as was mentioned i i
helped co-organize an annual conference
on
bioinformatics and computational biology
we just run last year our eighth annual
conference on computational biology and
bioinformatics that was last april
um the link is here um
and i'll provide these slides for for
distribution by pine biotech
and we had a whole session in the last
conference that was on the nih strides
initiative and this is an initiative
that nih has kicked off to
help with the transition to cloud
computing and we had a keynote talk
from amazon web services which is one of
the providers in nih strides and another
keynote from
the google cloud research group which is
another provider of
nih strides compute
we had other imminent bioinformatics and
computational biology speakers
and these topics that they covered
included the covid19 pandemic modeling
gut microbiome
herpes virus and the role of statistics
and epigenetics research and so here was
the flyer from
our conference from 2021 all the
speakers that we had and we're very soon
going to start uh organization of the
coming 2022 conference
and likely that'll be virtual due to the
ongoing pandemic it was virtual last
year and the 2020 conference actually
had to be cancelled because we didn't
have time to pivot to a virtual format
so my research lab just to give you an
idea at lsu um
one of the uh sort of tenants of the lab
when i built it is that i wanted it to
be an open uh environment so i didn't
put up partitions or cubicles or
anything like that
because i wanted to promote uh
the collaboration between all of the
students and and post-docs and
researchers that work in my lab
and that's served very well
essentially people sit around the
perimeter work at their workstations but
if they run into an issue they can just
turn around to their neighbor and um you
know ask and see if they if they have
enough
an opinion on how to resolve the issue
so i've had several people who worked in
the lab and have
rotated through it
and ongoing research projects
most of my research has shifted to be in
the vaginal microbiota and its
interaction with stis
i have a
major study on
chlamydia
trachmatis that virus and uh and
essentially how
the microbiome interacts with natural
clearance of the infection
i have another uh big project that's
that's running in south africa right now
on adverse birth outcomes
in that interaction with the microbiota
and then i have my
primary focus on uh bacterial vaginosis
i have a couple grants working on that
and then we just got a new grant awarded
where we're going to look at bacterial
vaginosis
and testosterone use in transgender men
and we're just about to undergo
uh start enrollment for that study and
most of this work is actually with my my
primary collaborator christina musney
who's at you university of alabama
birmingham
i'm also a member of the center for
clinical and translational research at
the university of alabama birmingham
and i'm a member of the louisiana
biomedical research network here
that is
flagshipped by the lsu campus in baton
rouge but extends throughout louisiana
as was mentioned early on i recently got
a an nsf grant which we've used to
establish a high performance computing
cluster at the school of medicine and
the lsu health sciences center here in
new orleans
it's a tiger fish cluster here's a
picture i took soon after it was
deployed
it's got
1440 total compute cores and a
193.6 teraflops
uh 36 compute nodes each of that which
has 192 gigabytes of ram it has
a very uh large ram memory node which
has 1.5 terabytes of ram and it's got a
gpu node as well
so it it serves a variety of purposes
for us and it allows us to perform some
of the
very compute intensive shotgun
metagenomics analysis that we need to do
lastly uh their lsu health sciences this
has been in progress for a while
my colleague here cendo hicks and the
genetics department has spearheaded a
bioinformatics track
uh within a master's program in
biomedical sciences and
we had intended to start enrollment of
that program a few years ago but the
kovid 19 pandemic intervened
and we
now have pushed the planned start of the
program to next fall
with an application deadline in april uh
but you know again the start of this
program is really dependent on
our evolving covid restrictions and
results of applicants to the program
whether we get that started or not
but the program its purpose will be to
integrate
instruction in computer programming
bioinformatics and computational biology
along with the myriad applications to
biomedical research that we do at the
lsu health sciences center
and
with that hopefully i'm somewhat on time
and i will
have an opportunity to take some
questions
thank you so much dr taylor it was a
really enlightening session for all of
us we got to know about a lot of
things about metagenomics a lot of
research applications and
various challenges and the ways to
address them as well
thank you so much for
your time and your presentation we do
have a few questions from our
participants which i will be taking up
one by one
and
you can address them
so
here's the first question that was asked
by our
audience and it's he says was the
patient of your study
was under some other medications because
during her mises
minses her biomass of lactobacillus had
almost disappeared but in the same
period she had other
dominant bacterium
colonies is this linked with the
physical presence of bacteria in the
body or was the lactobacillus phages
that you showed later responsible for
this depletion
so i will say uh not that we know of
so she so this was a prospective study
and women were enrolled in the study
and followed for 90 days and a an
exclusion criteria for enrollment in the
study was
having an sti or other
or being on any kind of antibiotics
within the past 14 days and so everyone
who was enrolled in the study
was healthy and and not on other
medications at the time
but this is a fairly high risk
population and so it's possible
that
due to you know sexual activity or other
other things that she may have
gotten an sti during the study
because they weren't being tested
throughout the study for that
essentially the samples were collected
for up to 90 days
and then when the samples were processed
if a woman was found to have bacterial
vaginosis she was called in
to get treatment
but the samples that we would have
worked on would have all been before
that so all of the data that i showed
you
would have been without any kind of
you know antibiotic treatment or other
drug treatment
being administered
prior to when those samples were taken
or sequenced so we do think that the
phage might have a role and that's
actually something that we're working on
right now that's why i'm so interested
in the results um that we're that we're
working on we've got a manuscript that's
uh that's about to go in for review
all right so
let's expand from that point as where
you said that depletion of microbes due
to antibiotics and the administration of
probiotics so
we know that probiotics are not really
verified by the fda
but in your opinion how effective they
are and what are the ways in which
probiotics are being improved through
modern research
so i'm very much at this point in time
a probiotic skeptic if you will
i think a lot of the market for
probiotics is a little bit of snake oil
because we don't
as a scientific community
know enough to really play god in the
sense that
when you have various conditions or
dysbiosis
we don't know exactly what needs to be
put back to fix that
and that's the best evidence of that is
c diff infections
um people have tried you know the the
standard attempts at
resetting a c diff infection is
antibiotics and often
it kills a bunch of organisms and makes
the condition worse well you try
probiotics you try all kinds of things
the thing that's been successful
is fecal microbiota transplant so take
fecal material a healthy bacterial
community from a healthy donor and
transplant it into someone suffering
from c diff and that's had almost 90
percent effectiveness rate
and the reason is well you put that
healthy bacteria back well if we knew
exactly what needed to be added we could
get around the idea of having to take
fecal material and implant it
but
we don't really understand that at that
level yet
what needs to be put back so you know
our probiotics good they probably are um
but
you really need to know which probiotics
and what they're gonna do
at this time they're not regulated by
the fda they're considered like
nutritional supplements
you know so
it's it's hard to really know what
you're taking and
what the results are going to be
all right thank you so much for the
answer here's another question from our
audience
he asked did you perform an in-silico
pcr test or some sort of evolution to
really get an insight on the primary
coverage for the 16s databases before
choosing the primer set and can you
please share your thoughts on how in
silico tests can be done to get maximum
coverage for amplicon sequencing
so what i'll point you to because it's a
very involved answer is we actually did
publish a paper several years ago
which was an in silico analysis of
several different primer sets
um
and you know my name is very common so
if you look for christopher taylor
you're gonna find people all over the
the gamut
but um you know a more uncommon name
that was my co-author on this paper
was elliot lefkowitz and if you if you
search for him
you'll you'll be able to find the paper
it's it it's got in silico in its title
and we did a whole analysis on the best
primer sets and we ended up
what we use in our microbial genomics
resource group is we we study the v4
region and part of that's due to the
limitations of the sequencing technology
we're using in in terms of how long of a
region we can study
more
more length if you can cover more hyper
variable regions is better
and in particular uh pacific biosciences
has
the you know they have a platform where
you can you can basically sequence the
whole 16s molecule and you can get down
to species level most of the time and
they're really pushing that technology
now we just uh we don't have that
sequencing technology in our lab
well all right definitely uh it's a good
idea to check out all the resources and
the papers that you have published and
kind of continuing from that particular
point there's a question in the chat and
it is about sharing the link
to your platform that you had mentioned
and your website and
he just wants to confirm it is it
metagenomics.lsu
hsc.com or not so it would be great
yeah let me type it in
metagenomics.lsuhsc.edu
um
that should get you there
all right well that's great thank you so
much for sharing and
uh here's the last question that i have
for you so you mentioned the various
sequencing categories and types and
their different pros and cons and their
challenges and what according to you
would be some of the computational
challenges that one might face while
doing metagenomics research and what's a
good way to
address them
well so computational challenges
um 16s ribosomal rna sequencing and
characterization that analysis is fairly
well worked out
there are really good tools that you can
use for that and the um
the analyses aren't super duper compute
intensive you can often do them on a
desktop workstation sometimes even a
powerful laptop like a macbook pro
but once you get the shotgun metagenomic
sequencing you're dealing with a lot
more data and there are tools available
to process the data but if you want to
do something
fairly
compute intensive like de novo assembly
of your sequencing reads you really need
access to a high performance computing
cluster like tiger fish and that's one
of the you know main applications that
we pushed in our
in our grant application to get that
platform was that you know we need this
sort of resource to be able to
do shotgun metagenomics analysis at
scale
all right well thank you so much for
your answers dr taylor and here's
another request in the chat to kindly
share the link through which our
participants can apply for the ms
program at lsu that you were talking
about
right i will
see if i can copy it
and
paste it into the chat
so that link should get you to
the page about the program itself and
then there's information on that page
that allows for
you to find out where to go to apply
right and there's someone who also wants
to ask about this ms bioinformatics
program that is it and remotely taught
program because due to the travel
restrictions for covid
and
the person being an international
student can he travel to louisiana right
now or
there's a method for distant learning as
well
so um
that's to be determined at this point uh
chindo and i have had discussions about
that i like the idea of having
a um you know virtual option
uh
kendo himself is actually from
africa and so he has an association with
several universities in africa and his
idea behind the program was that we
would have sort of
this crossing of
we bring a lot of students here to the
us
from south african universities
and uh of course covet kind of got in
the way of all that and so everything is
still
evolving right now we've had a
a number of new
leadership in our graduate school who
may be more
open to the idea of virtual programs so
we're trying to push that but for right
now
what i was discussing with the fall
the plans for that if we're able to go
forward with it would be to start that
program up as an actual
normal in-person
um master's program where you have a
residency here
uh where you're here for the education
but in the future
hopefully we'll be able to come to some
kind of a balance
well all right thank you so much dr
taylor for your time it was
wonderful to have you with us and
your talk was full of insights full of
information and it was a pleasure to
learn from you and also talk to you
thank you so much for your